trees are some of the biggest organisms
on the planet but where do they get that
matter to grow which nutrients ate the
ground
stats or any goodness out of the soil us
please
comes out of a soil yeah goodness
goodness why isn't there a big hole
around the tree where it's taken out all
the soil does it's a gradually let the
soil has time to recover now I think
it's intuitive to believe that the tree
gets most of its mass from the soil
because you can see those roots digging
into the soil and they must be taking
something out of there and I mean a tree
looks like dirt and it feels solid like
dirt but it's not in the early 1600s a
scientist named Johan Baptista van
Helmholtz tried to figure out where the
mass of a tree was coming from so he got
a pot of soil and very carefully
measured the amount of soil in there
then he planted the tree and took care
of it for five years making sure that no
soil left or was added to his pot and at
the end of this experiment he laid the
tree to find that it was 72 kilograms
but the mass of soil had only decreased
by about 60 grams this was pretty strong
evidence that the mass of the tree does
not come from the soil I've never
thought about that actually because they
don't really eat anything crazy they
don't eat me no no they don't eat
anything more so it's always absorb
that's all they eat yeah they don't eat
anything else no that's all they eat
well presumably from the water and the
nutrients from the soil is there
anything else that you need besides the
soil in the water especially late isn't
it to make a lot of other than the
original seed for that particular
trailer the seed in the soil and the
water and that makes this big tree of
course
Johan Baptista van Helmholtz did
conclude that the tree was made entirely
of water now while that's not correct at
least he was on the right track
realizing that the matter of a tree
doesn't come out of the soil the Sun
energy yeah
the Sun energy yeah are they converting
energy into mass or do you know what I
mean yeah like that there wasn't there
wasn't stuff and then there was like
where did that stuff come from
magic my question is where do they get
that mass to grow big Sun you from the
rain and the Sun presumably like a
sunlight and the sunshine the sunshine
does it does the sunshine add mass to
the trip um well it yes it wouldn't they
wouldn't grow without it I don't know
what it adds mass but they wouldn't grow
without it of course the sun's energy is
needed for the tree to build the matter
into its branches and leaves but the Sun
itself the energy is not matter well I
suppose a good for air into this as well
if yeah that's got to do something at a
yet you know what is it barrier I guess
in the air that it needs as well
oxygen the trees near the arc severely
they often go by and I guess oxygen the
oxygen of course the oxygen are there
any ingredients that we're missing
um-hum dockside carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide so would it surprise you to find
out that 95 percent of a tree is
actually coming up from carbon dioxide
trees and largely made up of air yeah
let's pause it yeah yeah honey I need
this reaction like oh so as it turns out
trees are mostly made out of air out of
the carbon dioxide that they take in
what's interesting is that we breathe
out carbon dioxide and water that's how
we lose mass but it's the exact same
substances that trees breathe in to gain
mass so if you can imagine a closed
system where it was just you and a tree
you would breathe out that carbon
dioxide and water the tree would take it
in so you would get smaller while the
tree is getting bigger and in a sense
you're becoming the tree
Shh